This is temporary.
Hi, um, I'm Billie Brown.
I'm here for
the babysitter position.
Oh, um, uh...
Yo soy--
- You're the babysitter?
- I'm here
for the interview, sí.
Yes, sí.
Yes.
I'll follow you.
Yikes.
- And is this where you put her?
- Yes, in the sitting room.
- Hello, hello!
- Welcome!
- Hi!
- This is our home.
Can you believe it?
- No, that's great.
Hi.
- Please, sit.
- Oh, that sounds like fun.
- It's Wilhelmina, right?
- Oh, or Billie.
Most people call me Billie.
- Or Bobbie?
- Well, no.
- This is my lovely wife,
Tanzy, and I'm Kent.
- Russell, yes.
I just read an article about
your new hybrid sports car line.
It's so interesting
to read about--
- It makes me uncomfortable
when people tell me things
I already know about myself.
So we looked over
your résumé.
Very impressive.
Harvard.
both: Wow.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh, thank you,
but it makes me uncomfortable
when people tell me things
I already know about myself.
[chuckles]
- I don't understand.
- [giggles]
- Tanzy, do you understand?
- No, I was just thinking
about Danny DeVito.
"Twins."
[both laugh]
- It's funny.
Um, as you probably
also noticed,
I don't have a ton
of nannying experience,
but I love kids.
I'm sure I'd get along great
with your daughter.
- Oh, she's not mine.
I've never been pregnant.
I wouldn't be able to drive.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh, that--
Is that her?
Wesley Snipes.
- Yeah, it is.
Can I be honest
with you, Bill?
You know, my--my--
my daughter's a great gal,
but she had some trouble
with school.
- Uh, that's great.
I taught in grad school,
so I could tutor her.
- Oh, that's perfect.
- Yeah.
- I mean, she has to pass
her GED.
- I'm sorry?
- It was part of the deal
I worked out with the judge.
- Judge--What judge--
- Now, my daughter has--
How do I put this?
A criminal past...
present.
You know, I probably should
just let you two meet.
Oh, hey. There she is.
[rap music]
♪ ♪
- ♪ All this money,
all this money ♪
♪ What am I gonna do
with all this money? ♪
♪ All this money,
all this money ♪
♪ What am I gonna do
with all this money? ♪
- Oh, [bleep] shoot!
Am I late?
- No, no.
- I wanted to make
a good first impression.
Is this her?
She's gorgeous.
Is this your natural skin?
Can I touch it?
- Yeah, no, no.
- It's okay.
I like guys.
- Oh, who are you?
- This is my daughter,
Genevieve.
This is Bobbie.
- Oh, you can call me Gene.
Like Eugene Levy,
but just the Gene part.
- I thought you said
your daughter was seven?
- Oh, she caught us.
Oh, she caught us,
didn't she, Tanzy?
- This is a joke.
- I don't know.
- Yeah, we may have fudged
the age a little bit in the ad.
When we said "babysitter,"
we meant more of
a "court-appointed guardian."
- Is that an ankle monitor?
- What?
- Is that...
both:
An ankle monitor?
Is that an ankle monitor?
- Oh, my gosh. I can do
a spot-on impression of her.
- Yep. Yep.
- Okay, I don't have
the background with criminal--
- Come on, Bill. You never
had any trouble with the law?
- No, no, no.
I-I-I jaywalked once
to save a hurt bird.
- Bird.
- What are you doing?
- See?
You're practically twins.
- Yeah.
- It'll be, like,
constantly having
a gal-pal
to hang around with,
like "Sex and the City."
- Ooh, I'll be Phoebe.
I look the most like her.
You have to give it to me.
- That's "Friends."
- Hire her.
Oh, I should check
this out first.
- What are you doing?
No, no, no!
- I'm just making sure
we don't have
a Mrs. Doubtfire situation
on our hands.